sad thing his office actually on to it
no I'm getting out of there [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] out of there
nah no no no no no bunch of lies what a
kitchen I know I get it okay I see what
I see how you could have cheated Bob
were you in the fireplace originally
maybe you jumped out of there yeah I got
out I got out of the fireplace
okay so zombies got a keen eye out
because we think you're a lying liar oh
my god you guys suck so much can't you
at least spread out a little no we got
this on lock because we know you're here
and you're Jim by getting in trouble Bob
wait a minute what you douche bags I
want a boat if anyone wasn't staring at
the entire roof we'll new here this way
away from every sin it damn it damn it
damn it god I've gotten everything is
some what I want oh I hear some stuff
going on that would explain a lot
hi hi there hi Margy say hi he was
trying to become the mouth it kiss not
possible apparently he had a nap okay
where is um B Oh zombies smart the
hallways you loser
ha ha ha what ha ha what'd I do throw
some smashing wood nothing happened
yeah god no I'm just saying in general
like you know just in general just
reservation can we get like a color or
something
whoa greenish ish why is there a wiener
hidden behind this plant I just threw it
across the room ok no shoot it shoot
that wiener shoot the Wiener oh come on
guys come on don't I don't understand
oh come on
please in one morning believe in you I
want to believe in you got it I got it I
was like those green ish I said green
bottles aren't green was a little green
probably must have missed something kind
of fishy out there
oh I I had noticed there was a fish I
was wondering if we would go back to his
douchey fish ways hi I saw you from
above and I'm like hey say hi oh wait
wait a minute wait a minute think about
it
wait a minute why won't the door open
why that why that door won't open
what called ah close to where I was oh
geez I'm up on the second floor - Ethan
I'm moving on up do these side up hey no
one's gonna join me in my choir song no
I'm a box of choco pops oh how
delightful sounds delicious
whoa you're not in the kitchen
nope Sam
why where do you gotta go what are you
I saw that you come out from behind
there I saw that way just ran right
behind you that was I don't know where
are you odd wait you are a master hey
whoa whoa don't go complimenting way too
much here I was in the room with the
grenade launcher so it was like huddled
outside I just snuck right behind them
no I was watching Bob that's what
happened there he came out of the
grenade launcher room six inches behind
you sprinted okay and it's now something
else completely okay whoa good cuz we
couldn't make it too easy on him I
didn't even know haha oh my god I
haven't realized what are you doing to
that barrel what is going on Oh bleep
perfect
that's even I am amazed at my own genius
it's so dastardly incredible
so deviously amazing so incredibly
precise it's doctor what happened that's
horrible
he pulled a pole to me move okay what's
Andy doing exit Lance Oh mmm horizontal
B oh your dastardly Hamar zombie if you
had to describe my hiding spot in just
one word how would you say it won't
giving it away clearly just one just
used the word that is what he is like
hahaha it's a really crappy spot is
moving around wall hmm
op mmm-hmm I just love this fresh ocean
breeze hmm
really clears me out as I'm sunbathing
here mmm little fire mmm
Sunday behind the barrel